a beetlejuice sequel
seriously
welcome to soundtrack your sci-fi tv and
movie
[Music]
channel even though this isn't
technically sci-fi
beetlejuice is a great movie and um i
love it and it's been long rumored that
there was always going to be a sequel
but now it's been reported by the anchor
that one is back on track and that it's
actually going to get made potentially
made in the summer for a release early
2023
so
where does this rumor come from well
it's been reported in the ankle and it's
also been reported that michael keaton
and winona ryder have already signed on
and if this is going to be produced by
brad pitt's company plan b
so what is the chances that this is
actually happening this is actually true
well
michael keaton's had a bit of a
renaissance in the last for years
basically ever since birdman he's been
back in the limelight he's come back as
batman in the bat girl and originally
the flash he has done a series of really
great movies including his appearance as
the vulture in the mcu which he's going
to be returning for
i can actually 100 see him returns this
role not just because he's working so
hard at the moment and really enjoying
working by the looks of it but mainly
because
i just think michael keane is
beetlejuice it's a character that is
just embodies him his silliness and his
outrageous acting style so i can 100
see this getting done
also winona ryder is enjoying a bit of a
renaissance she is definitely a name
again on people's lips people remember
who she is so again this could be
actually an important thing for the
production company you've got two actors
who
i loved from the original but actually
are still relevant at the moment it is
going to be a sequel not a reboot so
thank the lord for that
but
is this a film we want to see a sequel
well it could be easily done beetlejuice
didn't die or anything at the end of the
movie so you know he could easily come
back and i'm sure they can think of some
imaginative reason why would own a
writer might be tempted to say those
immortal words
beetlejuice beetlejuice beetlejuice one
more time
so hey and again with special effects
the way they are nowadays if this is
done well
which i doubt it will be but if it is
done well
then it actually could be something that
is very funny and very interesting and
let's see what they do if warner
brothers green light it as i say it
could be in pre-production by the summer
and basically out by the end of 2023
so guys get in the comments tell me what
you think is beetlejuice a sequel you
want to see for me i'd love to see what
michael keaton could do with this i just
doubt that writers producers directors
nowadays would do this justice
personally i think this is very
dangerous becoming just a silly stupid
movie i think it's the kind of film that
was made in the 80s and 90s really well
and it just doesn't get made very well
anymore
it's maybe
for them not for now
but get in the comments and tell me what
you think also you can become a fully
fledged sidetracker and support the
channel hit the join button and if you
are new to the channel please like
subscribe hit that bell notification do
all the buttony things it really helps
us out and as always guys please stay
safe i'll see you next time
wow